hi everyone i'm excited to be part of
this meeting thank you for the
organizers for putting everything
together especially
uh with everything going on right now um
my name is nicole and i'm a phd student
in the berkshire lab at the university
of rochester today i'm going to tell you
about a project that's actually been
rapidly evolving in the lab since
quarantine
due to it being mostly computationally
based and it involves a tool that we've
developed in order to analyze epithelial
architecture
so just to orient you to my talk
uh to begin with i've got to kind of
split this into three
sections first i'm gonna briefly go over
some background and uh labs
interests um second i'll go over the
tool and how it works
and then lastly we'll look at uh what
we've learned from the tools so far
so what are we interested in this lab
our lab is interested in how epithelial
tissues are built and maintained
um so as many of you probably know
epithelial tissues are the most common
tissue type in the body
they come in different flavors so to
speak so for example we have
simple columnar epithelia that line the
intestine
and we have simple squamous in the lung
but all epithelial tissues are sheets of
cells that line surfaces of the body and
provide protection from the outside
environment
and oftentimes the sheets of cells are
organized into tissues with specific
shapes and these shapes are essential
for
function so here are a few examples
coming back to the intestinal cells
uh these are organized into both crypts
in the bottom here and villi
and this serves two functions um first
of the crips which house the stem cells
down here
are protected from the lumen so um
that's obviously important so that the
stem cells can keep replenishing
the cells that are shed from the top of
the villi
and then the villi themselves protrude
into the lumen to increase the surface
area and maximize nutrient uptake
um second example here is the kidney
epithelia these are organized into
tubules and the shape of the tubule
uh and the organization vary depending
on where
in the chain of the kidney they are
um but they're all optimized for their
specific function
and last of the alveolar cells in the
lung
are simple squamous and this is
optimized for
gas exchange so in all of these examples
the organization of the epithelial cells
is actually essential for the organs to
function properly and
misplaced cells are thought to lead to
diseases such as
cancer so how do cells organize into
these shapes
um there are many sort of behaviors that
drive tissue shape change and
development but as a lab we're
particularly interested in
these bottom two here so cell division
and cell integration
um the cell division in particular poses
a problem for
a tissue in that the cell undergoing
mitosis is greatly changing shape as
it's growing
and rounding and then it has to undergo
cytokinesis and the two dwarfs have to
be placed within the tissue
or without compromising the integrity of
that tissue
and just to emphasize that point here
are two movies of
cells that are undergoing mitosis um the
first example here
is uh there's drosophila follicular
epithelium while
on the right is a mouse intestinal
organoid in both
movies the membranes are marked in green
and then tubulin is marked in red
and you can see that in both the cells
have rounded moved apically in the
tissue
and then the two daughters are born
slightly out of the plane of the tissue
here it's round towards the lumen and
then in both examples after division the
two daughters return
basically and reincorporate back into
the tissue
and all while the rest of the tissue
isn't affected
everything remains intact and
everything's still functioning well
so we are using mdck cells
um for monolayers to look at how
epithelial layers are built
so mdck cells are derived from adult
kidney and as you can see from this
fixed imaging and from the movie
which i'll play the sheets of the cells
undergo many divisions even when the
tissue already looks pretty packed so
this looks pretty regular but you can
see
here highlighted many many cell
divisions and this is all happening
without these other cells being
compromised
um just to look at the side view of
these um
when we grow mdck cells on a
collagen-coated slide they form
polarized monolayers in culture
so they're not inherently polarized but
we can induce polarity
and here you can see that there's a
nicely packed sheet of cells and if we
look at the xc view
we can see that abc is localized
apically
so a marker of uh polarity apical
polarity here
and um also then just to point out we
use
floyd into stain for actin and then
flappy for the dna as well
um so these you know monolayers look
quite good
and by looking at them we could tell
they're a layer um but
actually we see a lot of variation in
the organization
across the slide so we can see
areas that are very sparse and very flat
we see nice areas like the example i
just showed you
and we can see areas where it looks
quite disorganized
so this implies that the unit
development of the
layer isn't uniform across the uh
slide and so we need a way
to classify these layers that is in an
unbiased and consistent manner
and that's where our goal comes in so
this um
the whole point of this project is to be
able to characterize mdck monolayer
development
in an accurate and unbiased manner and
that brings me to part two of my talk
which is what is at all and how does it
work
so just to quickly go over what we
expect an
mtck monolayer to look like um i'll show
you a few examples but just to go into
in a bit more detail
when the layers formed we see this
nicely packed organized uh
cells and then if we look at the xz
view we can see that the nuclei are l
towards the bottom of the tissue
and the actin is enriched along the
lateral and apical signal
surfaces sorry um so we know this by
just looking at the layer but we need a
way to computationally import this
information
pixel by pixel and determine where the
layer is
in the image so to do that we
um created a pipeline for image
acquisition so
first off we plate ourselves on a
collagen coated slide as i've said
um and then after 24 hours we fix and
stain the layers
and then we image the same 16 positions
within the well so this as i said the
organization across the well doesn't um
appear to be uniform so we don't want to
be picking and choosing where we image
and then once we have these images um we
use the cells tool in a mars to segment
out all of the nuclei in the image
shown down here and this then gives us
the x y and z positions of all the
nuclei as well as the volumes
so then we can use this information as
well as the original
corresponding image file to load into
our automated layer analysis tool which
is alan
so the first step in here is to go
through the nuclei and just filter out
anything that
has been segmented that isn't a true
nucleus so anything that's probably
debris or anything that's just
crazy too big um so that we get all of
the
signal that seems to be a real nuclear
and then
um we run this along with the image file
through uh the rest of the script and
this determines where the layer is by
looking at both
the positional information of the nuclei
as well as the actin signal
so we go through um step by step in
z summing the x y uh actin signal and
this gives us the blue profile here
and then we can set the bottom and the
top cutoffs based on that actin signal
so i'm not going to go into any more
detail specifically for just for time
sake about how this works but if you
have any questions feel free to email me
um and we went through just to make sure
that this
seems to be working uh well and we a few
of us in the lab
took um some examples said where we
thought the top and the bottom of the
layers were
and uh compared that to allen and we
matched up pretty well
um one thing i just want to point out
here as well is that there is quite a
lot of variation
in manual uh determination of the top
and the bottom of the layer so this just
emphasizes the fact as to why we want to
actually do this computationally
but overall we matched up pretty well
with these
measurements that the tool is uh giving
us
so we can also tell from these images
and from loading everything through the
script whether or not our cells have
actually formed a layer
so we can go through and then based on
where the nuclei profile is
in a relationship to the actin profile
we can say whether or not the layer is
actually too flat so it's not actually a
proper layer it's probably a unpolarized
layer um
we can say whether it's too disorganized
so this one looks like the cells can
just kind of
clumped up on top of one another rather
than forming a nice uh
layer and you can see that the action
profile looks pretty crazy on this side
um and we can also just you know only
then focus on the ones that are just
right for the analysis that we wish to
do
um so just to point out here this works
really well on
examples that form either really flat
layers
very disorganized layers or are very
clearly a layer the borderline examples
are giving us a little bit of trouble
right now but we're optimizing that
so i just want to point that out and
then so for that reason the rest of the
presentation has also been manually
verified all of the data
so coming to that what is it that we've
learned from alan so far
so um one of the things that we actually
can get from alan is that we can
distinguish between developing
mature layers so we see that at eight
hours post-plating
the image is classed as a layer
according to alan
and all of the nuclei are towards the
bottom of the actin signal
and the um we get the nice uh
acting curve here um but the
as we go through time we start to see
this
little shoulder appearing in the actin
signal and a sharper peak for the apical
signal here
so um we can see that in the projection
as well that the
uh apical signal seems to becoming more
intense
as well as the lateral signal as the
layer becomes more organized
so as it becomes more regular we get to
see this specific
uh profile in the actin which is pretty
cool
um so another thing that we have found
from
alan is that between eight hours and 24
hours
when we pleat 200 000 cells we actually
see that
um at eight hours none of these images
are classed as a polarized layer
the majority of them are actually
unpolarized and flat
but over 24 hours we see a good
proportion of these actually becoming
polarized layers so
this is good that we can actually work
this out but we wanted to know
whether this polarization is actually
due more to
cell proliferation or reorganization of
cells over time so
in order to answer this question we need
to tease apart
either we need to tease apart time and
density and layer development
so to do this we can do various
different manipulations to ourselves so
we can change the initial plating number
either 100 000 versus 200 000 and we can
change the time
8 hours 24 hours or 48 hours and or we
can actually change
and stop cell division so we can use a
g1 inhibitor
um to stop the cells from dividing to
then
see just what contribution the
reorganization of cells can have over
time
so we did these three different
manipulations but for each one the data
i'm going to show you
is all the same final density so this
way we've decoupled
um density from time or cell number
initial cell number that is um and
division so
we're looking at all the same final
density but we've got there in different
ways
so when we look at that data we actually
see
that um if we treat the cells with
riscovitine which is that g1 inhibitor
that is um
saying about we see that actually
none of those over 24 hours form
layers so all of them are unpolarized or
disorganized
so but if we look at um
the same plating number initially and
the same time period
we see that actually that a lot of these
form uh nice polarized layers
so this way we've uncoupled time
cell number and just looking at cell
division here and it seems that
cell division might actually primarily
be driving the organization of
the layer and it's not really the
initial cell number
or time that matters um so that's kind
of cool
we want to look into this in a little
bit more detail and how we're going to
do this
is to build a computational model to
further tease apart the relationship
between division time
and layer development so by doing it
this way
we can manipulate individual variables
and look
and see what uh combination of variables
actually are giving us the layers that
we see
um so with that i'll just conclude so we
have developed a custom script that
determines whether or not
mdck cells have formed a nice smaller
layer um we can determine how many
nuclei
are within that layer and on top of them
on the layer too i didn't go into that
with so much detail but we're doing a
lot of work with that
um and we can look and determine the
stage of the layer development
so the number of extra layer nuclei also
increases resultant see i didn't show
you this
um but we are looking very much into
whether or not the
extra layered nuclei are there because
of
um cells just landing on top initially
and cells landing on top and then
dividing
um or cells leaving the layer or both so
we're looking at that
and we also have seen that organization
is actually independent
of cell density and time but definitely
requires subdivision
so moving on we want to use this
computation modeling to further
investigate this relationship
between cell division time and layer
formation
and we're currently making our script
more user-friendly and doing the
optimization that i mentioned at the
beginning
um so it can be more accessible to other
people to use
and we are starting to look at our labs
molecules of interest primarily
sardisian molecules and we can
manipulate these individually and then
see how they also affect
layer formation um so with that i'd like
to thank
my lab this is how we've all seen each
other recently during quarantine um
in particular i'd like to thank another
phd student in the lab christian who's
helped me a lot with the coding um i'm
not a computational biologist
so without him this would have been a
lot slower um
and with that if you have any questions
feel free to email me
thank you for listening